yes una gran Alegria para nosotros pasar
you'll do we are really delighted to
spend this day interest reston is one of
the most beautiful cities in Europe
record through a de Havilland
recuerdo el bombero you
I remember the terrible bombing shortly
before Germany surrendered in 1945 eagle
that's why I really want to see Dresden
now that it's been rebuilt
so the total motion and we are very
moved by this place of reflection and
meditation
Yallah meditation
I thought they were happy and moved and
also surprised we heard how beautiful
dress that is but being here we're
really quite overwhelmed Oh master bring
me
my abuelo era le monde el paradis me my
grandfather was German
I always listened to the way he infused
about the Germans and their beautiful
country he bore love ages are the early
money
now we're going to look at the most
famous paintings in the world
I mean sitting there you're joining us
remember I'm 78 and it's very moving to
see Raphael's painting of the Madonna
that for the first time
the name of mucha now we're hungry we
could get ourselves a German sausage
well typical of the region
why not it tastes really good a
delicious sausage but sadly it's now
time to say goodbye to this wonderful
city it's been an amazing day this
grassy address in thank you dress for
the food and all the beautiful things